Since having multiple tapes makes
programming with Turing machines more
convenient, and since it provides a nice
intermediate step for getting into more
complicated models, we'll look at this
Turing machine variant in some detail.
As shown in the figure here,
each tape has its own head.
And what the Turing machine does
at each step is determined solely
by its current state.
And the symbols under these heads.
At each step, it can change
the symbol under the heads, and
move each head to the right or
the left, or just keep it where it is.
With the one tape machine,
we always force the head to move.
But if we required that condition for
multitape machines, the differences in
head positions would always be even,
which leads to awkwardness
in programming.
So it's better to allow
the heads to stay put.
Except for those differences, multitape
Turing machines are the same as single
tape ones, we only need to
redefine the transition function.
For a machine with k tapes,
the new transition function is from
the Cartesian product of the possible
states of the machine, and the possible
symbols under the tape heads to the new
states of the machine times the symbols
to write under the heads times the
possible directions to move the heads.
Everything else stays the same.